frente a la penitenciaría de Guayaquil
la calma parece haber vuelto horas
después de que 2,600 soldados tomaron el
control de la prisión pero familiares
siguen preocupados por la situación de
los presos nosotros venimos a averiguar
que
por mi ppl por nuestro hijo y no nos dan
información supuestamente hasta el lunes
que da el slime da la orden para que de
información antes que nosotros no
sabemos si está herido A dónde están no
sabemos nada de nosotros de nuestros
hijos esta semana a varios actos de
violencia estallaron dentro como afuera
de la cárcel la más grande de Ecuador
según las autoridades fueron provocados
por el traslado de mil de reclusos a
otros recintos para reducir el
hacinamiento ante la bola de violencia
afectando a varias prisiones de las
provincias de guayas y esmeraldas el
presidente Guillermo lasso decretó
extender el estado de excepción y el
toque de queda nocturno he tomado la
decisión de incluir en el decreto de
estado de emergencia
a la provincia de Santo Domingo que ha
sido también afectado por actos de
terror desde el día martes hasta el
momento
Ecuador Es un punto clave en la ruta que
lleva la cocaína desde Sudamérica hacia
varios puntos del mundo el presidente de
la actual culpado en repetidas ocasiones
a las bandas de narcotraficantes por
liberarse una guerra en las calles y en
la superpobladas cárceles donde las
masacres han dejado casi 400 muertos
desde febrero del 2021